Cảm cái năm như chưa?
Cứ là đẹp lại dễ sợi nó không có khác
có mình thì cũng là đẹp lại đi học về làm bài tập của mình tập
thì thời gian không có dù khẩu thấy mò lượng
cho mình sẽ chả dạ cho tế việc của mình nghĩ quyền nằm bị chơi
Chưa học lức nằm hết
đùa bên đàn thè học lức bài
Ở nó khó không?
Không có dù gì hết?
Mở hôm mửi tinh ăn họng
Nguyên giáo trình mở dạ là to ngọt dạc tình
Cái mấy họng
Chị mà mình không biết một cái ngọng nữa
mà mình sống cho một cái đất đất đất,
mà mình không có cái ngọng nữa rất là khó chịu
Mẹ tập cầu bán nó gì mình ngồi đám
mình cũng biết mà nè nó gì
Mở sạch tế không phải rồi
Bán đứng được bán nó chịu
mình nó không chịu gì đâu mà mình lại tụi mình ngồi đây làm gì